I'm very excited about today for a
variety of reasons and not only for the
exciting panels we have but this is
Columbia it's my home and I spent the
better part of 10 years here going to
engineering school and law school
actually got a medal here is really very
nice place to be and this is sacrosanct
it's the heart of Columbia and they
couldn't have given us a nicer plot spot
it's just beautiful and I hope you all
enjoyed it many of you have been with
the forum from the beginning starting at
Yale and transporting ourselves to
Columbia I wanted to be closer to home
and we we made it and they were happy to
have us so it's great and for those of
you who started with us at yell I'm sure
you're just as comfortable here you
don't have as far to go and there's
nothing like this at Yale anyhow we this
is Columbia and we're glad that we're
here now we have a few announcements I
have an announcement to make good
corporate governance depends on doing
the right thing at the right time and
David the nirenberg and I who have been
co-chairs of the center from Yale to
here for 10 years decided on succession
it's time and we went through our
governance committee and suggested to
them that in accordance with good
corporate governance it was time for
them to think about succession and that
we we were ready and volunteered to do
the right thing which is get out of the
way when it's time to get out of the way
so we needed a new a new chairman we
were lucky enough to have bill McCracken
who had been vice chair for quite a
while knows the field extremely well who
volunteered unwillingly to become the
chairman he's delighted to do it and I'm
announcing that the Governance Committee
without hesitation Matt talk and pick
bill as the next chairman and he will be
and has now been elected as the next
chairman and I think you will be
delighted about it
just want to make a remark or two about
bill number one it was time to have
somebody who had actually gotten his
hands dirty in the business of corporate
governance bill has been a CEO has been
a chair has taken a very difficult
company and brought it back to life
computer associates he took them at the
bottom and he brought them to him top I
believe he invented the cloud and in any
event he knows corporate governance
inside out for having done that and
before that period of time had a
distinguished career at IBM so he knows
the field and he knows the business and
he knows technology and that's where
we're going and he couldn't be a better
choice to be the next chairman in
addition to all of that a rarity in
academia the faculty actually likes him
that's a that's a Stefan right direction
bill has been working with our faculty
advisors Jeff and Rob for some years and
they appreciate him beyond belief in
terms of being able to kick things
around with him in real time instead of
talking to people who think they know
corporate governance they're talking to
a man who's been there and done that and
brings a real-life attribute to the
center which is terrific and his
relationships with both investors and
the corporate community is unparalleled
everybody likes bill everybody trusts
him everybody knows he's not biased in
one direction or the other but he
understands the full scope that we need
to deal with both investors and the
corporate community in order to come out
right so I look forward to where we're
going oh by the way the Dean likes them
which is very important in academia so
we have a rounded picture of a new
chairman who is well liked well versed
and knows the field and is practiced in
it I don't think we could be luckier to
have bill and I know you'll all welcome
him and
as the ideal candidate who is now taking
over his chair as far as where we're
going from here bill was certainly going
to lead us the Governance Committee
asked David and I to hang around I
didn't have to ask us to hang around so
we're going to be called founding chairs
whatever that means but with here and we
will continue to be associated as
heavily intellectually as we ever were
in the center I'm not going anyplace and
I intend to work with Bill as his
partner and achieving the new directions
that we're going and what are the new
directions the new directions are
evolutionary we came here originally
from Yale to study the intermediaries if
you recall we wanted to get to know more
about who stood between Main Street and
the corporate community host of
intermediaries papers had been written
saying it's about time studied that and
we spent our first couple of years among
other things studying the intermediaries
in the project called crown which will
be described to you by Rob in very short
order we want to build on that now that
we have a better picture and have an
academic base for studying that a little
further a lot further we can go from
there to what comes next and what comes
next is to recognize that the capital
markets have changed completely since
governance was invented back in the 70s
and 80s since same capital markets and
the question is with a new understanding
of the intermediaries how are the
capital markets affecting corporate
governance there's nothing more
important to think of at the moment and
we concluded that the basis of the work
would be to study the role of the board
I'm not going to go into that in great
length because you'll hear all about
that today the question is how does the
board deal with what it's confronted
with at the moment namely this array of
shareholders some good some bad but
they're there we're not going to change
that and we can't legislate it out of
existence it's real it's there
has to be dealt with how does the board
of directors which has the
responsibility for the future of the
corporation how does it deal with this
what kind of directors do we need what
kind of things do we have to do this is
not simple there's a long-term project
and the center is the ideal place to do
it because we've been thinking about it
for a long time we now have some tools
to work with we're at an ideal academic
center where our faculty really believes
that's the problem of the future or
issue of the future and is prepared to
help us devise not only academic studies
but practical studies of where we go
from here so it's a very exciting future
we have we're seeing the evolution of
the center from where it was which was
at the beginning sort of a talk shop but
moving from that to studying the
intermediaries I'm moving from that
they're now considering the role of the
board and what the rector's ought to be
like it's a natural evolution and after
10 years with a place to do it columbia
is the place to do it to law school and
the business school which will be
working with us other places to do it we
have people who really care about this
issue at Columbia to them it's important
and we couldn't be at a better home so I
welcome you all and I welcome bill will
be up here in a minute and tell you that
we have an outstanding chair at which
david and i are very very proud and i
know you will be two and we're not going
away so bill welcome
you